[Music]
i have to know
have you watched siesta key no but i've
heard a lot about it i've heard a lot of
people say that it's a wannabe laguna
and it's not good
so no one reached out to you and said
anything or no i just saw um i never go
on twitter anymore and i happen to be on
twitter i think it was when it first
aired uh-huh so i was like why do i have
all of these mentions and then i was
reading a couple and everyone's like oh
my god i don't know
i heard that trl is coming back too
i mean listen i love it like that's i
loved mtv back in the day singled out
trl those that was cool mtv yeah so hey
if you guys want to try to redo that it
does well good for you as mtv tries to
recreate that laguna beach and hills
magic kristen cavalieri tells e.t she's
still close with the majority of her
former co-stars i talk to heidi and
audrina all the time and then
both alex alex's from laguna who have
babies i mean literally everyone has
become a mom it's really cool to see but
i talk to them all the time as well i
saw that spencer and heidi are hoping
that their soon to be born son
marries your daughter
do we think of that area
so it should be a slightly cougar yes um
that's so funny i i didn't know that
they announced it was a boy so i'm glad
that's out and i'm not the one who
ruined that yeah
that's funny i mean okay bring it yeah
we'll see are you ready for play dates
yeah i mean it's just hard because we're
in nashville and everyone's in l.a but
you know yes the kids do come out
[Music]